[Music]
welcome back to Hannity all right for
more on the midterms Jeff Sessions
resignation today we go to the great one
Mark Levin host of see our TV's Levin TV
number one by the way your ratings were
killer on suddenly we do our break one
life thank me life liberty and Levin
right here on the Fox News Channel let's
start with the results I want three
topics for you you can do go in any
order I want your take on the results
your take on the media and your reaction
at Jeff Sessions resignation today well
you know Sean in many ways it's it's one
of the same things the media were very
angry today at that press conference and
you have to wonder why I thought the
president they said had a lousy night
you know the Democrats take about thirty
four seats and I want the American
people to understand what that means is
they have an 11-member majority in the
house and with that 11 member majority
most of which are Republican seats they
intend to do everything they can to
[ __ ] the executive branch and [ __ ]
the presidency and I'll get back to that
in a minute
what we saw today in that press
conference was a disgrace to this
country imagine the world watching what
took place there
these kamikaze journalists obviously in
a coordinated attack on this president
they're trying to [ __ ] this
presidency they are trying to sabotage
this presidency it's not going to work
but that's what they're doing they are
furious that this blue way was a blue
tinkle last night because that's all it
was
and they've been talking about blue wave
they've been beating down this president
beating down the Republican Party
beating down these candidates they pull
out their racist tool to use their white
supremacy tool to use they pull out
their Nazi tool to use their Hitler tool
to use they tried everything they could
you can't tell the difference between
the Democrat talking points and the
media in this country because in many
respects they're one and the same thing
survey after survey over the decades
have shown us that most in the media are
liberal most live and operate on the
eastern seaboard in the Western Seaborn
well look what's going to happen now in
the House of Representatives look at the
diversity of Marxist and Leninist pretty
much the Finance Committee Maxine Waters
L
the let's see the House Oversight
Committee
Jerrold Nadler Manhattan the House
Intelligence Committee Adam Schiff la
Elijah Cummings beheading the Oversight
Committee as well he will be from where
Baltimore and then of course you have
Nancy Pelosi San Francisco so over here
and over here what about the middle of
the country and the rest of the country
they're not going to be represented
because the Democrat Party is controlled
by these hardcore hardcore leftists I am
sick and tired of these media types
trying to hijack these press conferences
these press conferences are for the
American people
CNN you don't even have an audience it's
not for you it's not for MSNBC and it's
not for every harebrained malcontents
miscreant Democrat liberal dressed up as
a journalist you know we have standards
in this country for doctors for lawyers
for truck drivers for plumbers for
electricians what are the standards for
journalists fake tapper fake tapper was
a spokesman for a Democrat congresswoman
then he was a spokesman for handgun
controlling now he's a journalist
there's a guy that used the work for
Obama who works at CNN now he's a
national security reporter what are
their standards there are no standards
for journalists today and let me tell
the journalists you say tell the
president stop saying stop saying the
media or the enemy of the people now
he's not saying the whole media he said
that a thousand times
let me tell the media something the
president isn't the enemy of the people
either and you should stop your campaign
of trying to [ __ ] him and destroy him
they're upset because there was no blue
wave they're upset they lost in 2016
they're upset they lost in 2018 and
guess what they're gonna lose in 2022
now as for sessions that's a
constitutional crisis don't you know
what's a constitutional crisis the
president got rid of a cabinet secretary
the Attorney General
he's only been telling us this for 10
months what he plans to do it's like the
Saturday night massacre they dragged up
John Dean the guy that doesn't even have
law license anymore the guy who who
served time as I seem to recall threw
water
now he's a contributor to one of the
watch CNN or MSNBC there's an authority
and what does he say it's like the
president's plotting to kill somebody a
murder well so he gets rid of sessions
what so what happens he has an acting
Attorney General then I hear these so
called experts he can't do that there's
a rule of success of course he can do
that
moreover they say it's like the setting
on a massacre how did he fire Muller did
you order the Attorney General to fire
Muller did the order the Deputy Attorney
General the muck farm oh he hasn't
ordered anyone to do anything the Muller
Muller still you know roaming the
countryside looking for people to
prosecute and challenge and so forth and
so on
nothing's happen but Schumer's there
Simmons there I think we have a
constitutional crisis let me tell you
something this is an important point I
have said that the appointment of Muller
is unconstitutional it violates the the
appointments clause and Schumer proves
my point every day you know why because
if Muller was just like an assistant US
attorney a US Attorney they wouldn't
keep saying he's separate protect him
he's different
he has to report to himself effectively
that's why his appointment is
unconstitutional because it's supposed
to go to this Senate and be confirmed
just a little nicety there that I wanted
to mention as well in any event the
Republicans had a very good night and
they had a good night quite frankly
because of the president it's the
president who held the Senate and some
of these excellent candidates and the
losses in the house could have been
worse but they weren't worse and that's
why the media are furious Sean that's
the bottom line and I'm gonna tell the
media something you're humiliating
yourselves you're embarrassing
yourselves the American people more and
more are turning on you're not because
the president says you're the enemy of
the people but because you act like the
enemy of the people you know what we
learned in this press conference today
thanks to the media
nothing a presidential press conference
isn't for CNN which doesn't have any
viewers anyway it's for we the American
people you ask questions to elicit
information from our president so we can
know what's going on you know mark I put
up Barack Obama in his first midterm
69 House and Senate seats Bill Clinton
63 times it's happened where a president
his first midterm wins as many seats
that's it yeah but he's they're liberals
they're Democrats they like them so you
know they get treated quite differently
all right great one we call you the
great one for a reason Mark Levin don't
miss life Liberty live in number one
show Sunday nights 10:00 p.m. you get to
see it all right here on the Fox News
Channel